ماذا عن تونس العلاقه مع تونس بنلاحظ انها
تبدو متقلبه وغير مفهومه احيانا وجزء من
المعارضه الحاليه وخاصه الاسلاميه انتقد
فرنسا كثيرا والجزء الاخر من المعارضه
التي كان يحسب على فرنسا اصبح ينتقد
موقفها من الوضع هناك كيف تقيم لي العلاقه
مع تونس
تونس شديد كبير لفرنسا وتونس بلد كان في
المقدمه في الكثير من التطورات نتذكر حقبه
الرئيس بورقيبه كانت حقبه كبيره حيث تونس
كانت مصدر تنوير بفضل نخبيها ثقافيه في
البحر الابيض المتوسط طبعا حصل الربيع
العربي في تونس ايضا واليوم نحن في حقبه
تتسم بالكثير من الاضطرابات هذا بلد شاب
له جيل من الشباب يريد ان يتقدم اذا يعود
الامر لنا نحن الفرنسيون طبعا بلد قريب من
تونس تاريخيا ان نكون متاحين لمساعده
التطوسيين عند الحاجه ونستمع لتونس ولما
تطلبه على التونسيين ان يحلوا مشكلاتهم
الخاصه ويحدد مستقبلهم ولكن اعتقد ان
مسؤوليه فرنسا التي تتقاسم جزءا من تاريخ
هذه البلد المتوسطين تكون متاحه عندما
يحتاج غيرنا الينا احيانا تكون العلاقات
جيده واحيانا غير جيده او اقل جوده ولكن
من خلال هذه العلاقات يمكن ان نمضي على
اساس الثقه المتبادله